it's great to welcome to the program
today dr. Michael Ryan who's a professor
in the integrative biology department at
the University of Texas also a senior
research associate at the Smithsonian
Tropical Research Center in Panama and
he's also the author of a taste for the
beautiful the evolution of attraction
which is a super interesting issue that
you study correct me if I'm wrong dr.
Ryan you study issues of the evolution
of attraction across animal species but
there's also sort of some modern
socio-cultural implications to this
issue among among humans or Homo sapiens
though they're not I mean this is a
wide-ranging issue yeah my my research
is mostly about animals and this book is
mostly about animals but there's a lot
of research on sexual attraction in
humans and I weave that research into
the narrative of the book so let's talk
about maybe two of the broader to get us
into the topic there's sort of a couple
different views that sort of are out
there about sexual attraction between
members of the same species there's this
idea that there is sort of objective
traits that are attractive
evolutionarily and that the brains of
species recognize that and then there's
sort of another approach which is no
it's actually the brain that will sort
of determine what it is that is
considered attractive talk a little bit
about the history of the two approaches
yeah well they're they're sort of a mix
where both of those factors seem to be
important but historically researchers
have examined males because it's usually
the animals it's usually the males that
have these outlandish sexual traits like
the Peacocks tail is kind of the mascot
for these studies so the idea was well
let us examine the Peacocks tail let us
examine male sexual traits and try to
figure out what information they have
that they're sending to females and
females or under selection to figure
to figure out which males are better
than others the alternative and it's not
mutually exclusive but the alternative
that we emphasize is the females aren't
trying to figure out who is attractive
the females determine who is attractive
they're the deciders so the females
perceptual and cognitive and neural
architectures are all going to influence
what she finds attractive so yeah it's
been said beauty is in the eye of the
beholder but this is why we say more
generally beauties in the brain of the
beholder we want to understand why
traits are beautiful we have to view
them through the brain of the
individuals that make these decisions
about beauty now how does that happen at
the practical level because I think we
can imagine human women for example
getting together and having a
conversation about what it is that they
find appealing about the opposite sex
for reproductive purposes for example
but humans have society in a way that
that animals don't and some animals
really really don't depending on whether
we're talking about primates or other
animals so how is it that species are
deciding what it is that's attractive in
a potential reproductive mate their
brains are organized as are the brains
of humans that we perceive and react
more strongly to some stimuli over
others so for instance in humans we
cannot hear ultrasounds the kinds of
sounds that bats make or infrasound this
kind of sounds that whales make on a
finer level we find some sounds louder
than other sounds and this is true in a
lot of animals so for instance the frogs
that I study they have two ears in their
heads two separate ears and they detect
different sounds better than other
sounds and the male frogs have evolved
these kinds of sounds that match these
sensory tuning of the female's brain but
animals also have in a sense
conversations about what's attractive as
well there's something called mate
choice
yeah and if a female fish sees a male
fish courting another female all of a
sudden this female prefers that male to
other males in the school
his attractiveness goes up if she sees
that other females are interested in him
in humans there is sort of a social and
cultural element to the attractiveness
of certain traits right so like an
example would be if you look at the
world you have a very very different
interpretation for example as to the
sexualizing of female breasts right in
Western culture they are much more
significantly sexualized than in some
other cultures that is not an example of
an evolutionary process is it since it
appears to vary sort of based on culture
is there some analog to that in animal
species there yeah there's there's a
really striking analogy and that is with
dialect formation and birds so songbirds
learn their song and like any organism
that learns it makes mistakes so
different populations of birds of the
same species songs vowels are a good
example they tend to have slight
differences in their songs between
populations and these differences are
very much like differences and within
the same language of humans female
although these are cultural differences
in their passed down from father to son
culturally not genetically and the
females are exposed to the local sounds
the local dialects and then lay it when
they're growing up and then when they're
mature and ready to choose a mate they
prefer the local dialect to a foreign
dialect so that had that's you know very
parallel to cultural preferences that we
see in humans yeah although I mean I
guess in in thinking it through just now
as you're mentioning it that could
arguably be there could be some
evolutionary basis basis for that in
that hearing the local song you're
accustomed to transmit sir
applies maybe some degree of safety or
something like that because it's a known
entity where the sort of example about
the sexual ization of women's breasts
seems to be maybe more exclusively
socio-cultural I don't know I mean I'm
sort of thinking out loud here yeah well
with the bird example preference for
local dialects could it could be
adaptive the preference could be
adaptive if your mating with the male
who's familiar with the habitats in
which you live you're probably going to
get a male who's a better father than if
you get a male who's migrating into your
population from a population with very
different habitat structure with
different kinds of food sure there could
be an adaptive advantage in the human
case that you're mentioning I agree with
you there doesn't seem at first blush
there doesn't seem to be much of an
adaptive advantage in the way that that
female breasts are sexualized and in
fact when Darwin considered variation in
skin color in humans
Darwin suggested that that variation was
not adaptive at all but arose because of
cultural differences amongst females in
the skin colors that they preferred and
since there's no adaptive advantage this
is why you get different populations
having different preferences which then
can lead to the evolution of of
different skin tones in different in
different areas of the world so how
about within similar populations what we
would call personal tastes I guess would
be the way to say it you know it's very
common that humans even humans who grow
up in very similar situations exposed to
similar media etc develop what they call
particular tastes when it comes to what
they find attractive about potential
mates do we have some sense of what
mechanism is at play there no not
another very not a very good sense I
mean we certainly know that there's
variation in preferences we also know
that
in humans that preferences can be very
fickle
both female preferences and male
preferences and they can change rather
quickly I'll say Oh Mickey Mickey Dewey
wrote a country-western song do the
girls get prettier at closing time and
somebody did a study of men and women in
bars and they asked them to rate the
sexual attractiveness of opposite gender
patrons of the bar what they found is
that the assessment of people's
attractiveness got higher and higher and
higher as closing time approach and we
find the same thing in the animals that
we study as well right although the
animals probably are not being
influenced by alcohol consumption during
the evening I would guess that you know
that's a really good point so that study
was done quite a while ago but it was
redone recently in Australia you know
where beer is king and they did the same
study but they measured blood alcohol
levels and not surprisingly out blood
alcohol levels increased during the
night but statistically if you remove
the effect of blood alcohol levels so in
a sense you remove the effect of why we
called beer goggles right the phenomenon
was still there they still found that
members of the opposite gender were
quote-unquote getting more attractive as
the bar was about to close is the term
beer goggles a common one in the world
of integrative biology like is that is
this is what because some people might
be shocked to hear that that's a term
that would come up in your department no
it's actually it's not a term that you
would hear in in biology but it's a term
that I came across when I was in a bar
in Australia so it's a very common term
in Australia at least the book is of
course taste for the beautiful the
evolution of attraction we've been
talking about some of the subject matter
from the book with its author dr. dr.
Michael Ryan who is a professor in the
integrative biology department at the
University of Texas very very
interesting work and I really appreciate
you sharing it with me today well thank
you very much for your interest